[Music]
the idea that that organizations and
companies don't handle change all that
well it's just something that's really
in the background of a lot of
organizational research say we go to to
some huge company tomorrow and try to
understand what's keeping them from
adapting it's very difficult as a
scientist to really know okay like
what's happening here and how do I
measure these different things and one
evening I was just watching a video game
tournament and it just kind of hit me
that everything is observable in that
world that things change relatively
often in that worlds when I just
encountered that eSports setting there
was just kind of a ha moment
the videogame that I'm looking at is a
team video game where teams of five
people just have to play together in a
really coordinated way to win against
other teams you want something that has
an organizational character to it and
that is coordinated so it mean there are
lots of video games that are individual
that wasn't really interesting to me the
other aspect had to do with the data the
fact that the data is just available in
that game every mouse click is being
recorded which is if you'd like to play
with data this is pretty amazing there
was also the fact that players are
playing for millions of dollars which is
important for your just to make a
reasonable assumption that those people
are actually trying to win the actually
trying their best to be to be
high-performing we can be pretty
confident that whatever we're seeing
here has to do with just people trying
to coordinate with each other and as a
scientist being able to isolate that is
just pretty cool
organizations get faced by by change all
the time and they have new technologies
that become available I think very often
[Music]
the people who make decisions those
companies tend to think of new
technologies new tools as a way of
improving what they are doing right now
just just doing the same thing better
and that's pretty much the exact same
thing that I found in those video games
what's changing in the game are the
powers of the different heroes that
they're playing their first reaction
would be to just do the exact same thing
just with new tools they would actually
explore even less than when you with
them when you didn't have changed they
wanted to relearn the current strategy
with those new tools
most of the teams will quickly adapt
each of the pieces but they didn't
really think about how that enabled them
to just play differently as a team you
could argue that it would make sense but
that's like before doing any any type of
change you would try to get the
fundamentals right mythic trying to
understand how that change helps us do
what we're doing right now better what I
saw in the data is that teams on average
tended to forget about that second part
right there they got the basics right
and then they just stayed with the
business as it you could make an
argument that it makes sense just
because it makes you more efficient what
I was seeing it what I saw in the data
is that those teams actually tended to
lose more the teams that did adapt more
were those where everybody was
communicating together and really can't
seem to share how the change was
affecting them personally so that they
can have a brainstorm
about what they could do as a team to
address that there's also a lot of
changes that there are more you know
there are more indirect and they have to
do with know one small component of what
you're doing changing a little bit and
that having ripple effects on all of the
rest of what you're doing we understand
it to be those teams that didn't at
least didn't seem to assume that because
the change looks small the adaptation
that we should make would be small as
well that sometimes you know you had
this very what seemingly minor changes
in the code of the game in the heroes
that were selectable but they still just
try to play in a completely different
way
so in the video game world it really
seemed like the leaders that weren't
communicating too much and we're letting
their teammates participate to
decision-making were the ones that had
the most success were the ones that were
the most likely to look for these new
ways of working together whereas the
ones that were know that were just
against the only ones speaking
tended to be in those teams where you
would see this very local reasoning
which suggests that really can you know
crowd sourcing some wisdom from your
employees seems to work quite well now
one thing to keep in mind is that in
those teams the people who are the
leaders are also players right so you
could make an argument that it's just
harder for them to think of the big
pictures maybe people in companies that
are managers it's their entire job to be
a manager might have a better visibility
over the whole team but I think there is
an argument to be made for the fact that
they would still benefit from from
trying to understand how their employees
work together and and and actually
asking them how they think change is
affecting them and how that might impact
how they work together doing the
incremental effort of thinking okay how
does that impact the entire team how
does that impact not just that person
but how that person can work with others
maybe how even our unit is working with
the other units in the organization I
think can yield a lot of payoff actually
one piece of the paper that should make
us hopeful is that when I was comparing
the teams at the beginning of the
observation period to those that had
gone through several changes and had
just aged over time the latter ones
actually seemed to do better over time
it seemed like the teams that had gone
sort of changes just seem to know that
adapting systemically has had some value
so over time teams just got better at
adapting not just at the local level but
at the system level which kind of
suggests that this can be learned right
you you're not doomed to always at that
locally
[Music]
you